[Music]
on this sunday night marching for the
two michaels
the show of solidarity for the two
canadians languishing in a chinese
prison we find strength from
from all of you and the message from
their stoic families the conservative
flip-flop on guns the restrictions put
in place in 2020 will remain in place
plus the push for a national vaccine
passport let's make things streamlined
and easy as possible and breaking news
from guinea on an attempted coup where
is the president
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us 1 000 excruciating days and counting
that painful benchmark is how long
michael spavor and michael kovrick have
been stuck in a chinese prison the
campaign to bring the men back home to
canada has gone nowhere today their
families their friends and strangers
marched in ottawa to recognize the
courage and resilience of the two
michaels as mike armstrong explains in
tonight's top story loved ones are still
holding out hope that one day they'll be
reunited
it was a milestone marked by a march for
a reason one of the things michael
kovrig's family knows about his
detention is how he copes they say the
former canadian diplomat marches every
day in his small cell 7 000 steps
that was the number supporters walked
through the streets of ottawa i hope
that with every step that we take we
bring them one step closer to freedom
thank you
the two michaels were detained in
december of 2018 charged with espionage
kovrig and michael spavor a canadian
businessman who'd been working in china
for their families one thousand days
into the nightmare there was some energy
from the march
it's great to see the support from
so many people from so many walks of
life coming to just be here with us the
two michaels are being held in what some
have called hostage diplomacy their
detention came just days after the
arrest of a huawei executive in
vancouver on an extradition request by
the u.s government the american justice
department wants mung won joe to face
conspiracy bank fraud and wire fraud
charges in the u.s her next court date
in the process is october 21st
there's no question the chinese acted as
a result of that
foreign affairs minister mark garneau
took time off the campaign trail to show
his support and frustration the
detention of the two michaels came he
says on trumped up charges in a
tit-for-tat move for the lawful
detention of hmong
we respected our treaty obligations on
extradition with the united states and
and detained her and she is being
allowed full due process in law if they
can pick these two up they could pick
anybody up also in the crowd at the
march former diplomats gail tiermann and
michael dawson even at the height of the
cold war with the soviets they say
international diplomacy had unwritten
rules of engagement we never had the
soviets taking an ex-diplomat into
captivity as a sort of bargaining chip
the message on this day was that the
michaels aren't marching alone they have
support if not their freedom kovrik's
trial wrapped in march he's still
waiting for a verdict spaver was
sentenced earlier this month to 11 years
in prison but the most important
decision in their cases may be the
decision in mung's extradition case
still not expected for months
mike armstrong global news
ottawa the mission to free the two
michaels isn't the only issue following
justin trudeau on the campaign trail so
is the dismissal of one of his
candidates raj saney who's facing a
number of misconduct allegations has
dropped out of the race initially the
liberals stood by zany but as abigail
beeman is here to tell us the party
ended up kicking him out abigail
robin justin trudeau says raj sani is no
longer the candidate in kitchener center
after new allegations came forward but
he refused to get into any specifics
including about the type of allegations
i think everyone
is frustrated
me included certainly
the best answers we tend to be able to
give
on allegations of sexual misconduct or
harassment
is always
we we followed an independent process
we're following the rules trudeau said
in order to respect integrity and
privacy the liberal party can't say even
half as much as they would like after
allegations first surfaced that saney
harassed a former member of his staff
the liberals stood behind their
candidate but saturday announced a new
review process was initiated after new
information was provided to the party
and saney will no longer run for the
liberals saying he has firmly denied the
allegations conservatives meanwhile are
calling for further investigations
sending a letter to the clerk of the
house of commons asking him to look at
whether the workplace harassment policy
was properly applied due to the timing
it's too late to change names on the
ballot meaning there's no chance the
liberals can win kitchener center
trudeau said if saney managed to get
elected he would not be part of the
liberal caucus
obviously this is a far from ideal
situation that we
no longer
have
any candidate in that riding in a
statement the woman who reported saney
for inappropriate workplace behavior
said people who experience questionable
conduct should not feel hesitant to
speak out this culture of tolerance
needs to change
i asked trudeau whether he felt he let
down either people who came forward with
complaints or liberal supporters left
without a candidate but he did not
directly answer just repeated they went
through the process when they learned of
allegations a year ago and the
independent conclusion at the time was
they could proceed
robin abigail beeman in markham ontario
after days of questions about his
party's gun policies conservative leader
aaron o'toole is changing his tomb he's
now vowing if elected he'd maintain a
liberal ban on assault style weapons
here's michael couture on what prompted
the reversal
[Applause]
for two days questions about gun control
have hung over aaron o'toole like west
coast clouds sunday unprompted the
conservative leader sought to clarify
his position the present ban on a number
of other firearms that were reclassified
in 2020 will remain in place it was a
clarification but also a reversal from
what is clearly written in the platform
that he proudly parades around to every
event on page 90 it says a conservative
government will start by repealing c-71
and the may 2020 order in council that
order is better known as the liberal ban
on assault style weapons we will conduct
a transparent review of the firearms
classification process
to take the politics out of this process
and engage the public in decisions with
respect to public safety
trying to make this a ballot box
question liberal leader justin trudeau
started his day flanked by posters of
guns that he says the conservatives
want to make legal mr
o'toole has made a secret deal with the
gun lobby
to reverse that ban
on these assault weapons mr trudeau
claims today that you have a secret deal
with the gun lobby do
you maintaining the status quo that's in
place right now that's not the question
sir what we're trying to do is to make
sure that we have a process to take the
politics out of this a senior
conservative source tells global news it
became clear the liberals wanted to make
this an issue for the entire week so
o'toole added the explanation to his
announcement at the last minute
o'toole's clarification comes less than
a week before the next two leaders
debates that could help blunt some of
the attacks from his opponents but it
could also open him up to criticism
about his lack of clarity when he was
first asked about the issue
robin michael couture in vancouver
ndp leader drag meet singh spent the day
in ottawa advocating for a national
vaccine passport and as matthew bingley
explains singh is also calling for a
rare moment of unity from his political
competition
to get the country through the next
phase of the pandemic ndp leader chuck
mead singh says canada needs a national
vaccine passport why not use the
resources we have at the federal level
to come up with a document that makes it
easy to prove this is me i've been
vaccinated so far four provinces either
have programs in place or in development
where proof of vaccination is needed to
access facilities activities or events
last week ontario's premier blamed
justin trudeau for not creating a
federal vaccine passport program after
months of saying his government didn't
want one imagine traveling around even
canada with 13
different vaccination certificates
it would have been much easier if we had
one passport federal passport new
brunswick doesn't have a passport system
but its premier says one may be needed
for travel while alberta's government
remains against them there are provinces
that don't do it but you got people that
want to travel into a province that that
requires proof what do they do then they
they've got a complication if someone
wants to travel to quebec and they've
got to show proof to get into an event
or to go to a restaurant for them it
would make their life easier the
liberals are pitching one billion
dollars to help provinces develop
vaccine certificate programs but are
keen to keep it out of federal hands
first of all movie theaters and
restaurants being provincial
jurisdictions is exactly why we are
offering to the provinces to pay for the
vaccine certification or mandate
programs uh right after we announced
that we were going to do that ontario
finally stepped up and did the right
thing
after protests over vaccine policies saw
health care workers and patients
harassed outside hospitals throughout
canada last week the ndp leader is also
proposing changes to the criminal code
if he's elected to make it an
aggravating offense an aggravating
element to in any way
impede or assault or enemy threaten a
health care worker in the course of
their duties it is just not on jakmit
singh is asking the federal leaders to
come together and record a nonpartisan
message encouraging people to get
vaccinated so far both the liberal and
conservative leaders have agreed to take
part robin matt bingley in toronto
a three-year-old boy who was missing in
quebec for more than four days has been
safely reunited with his mother police
say a standoff with the man who
allegedly abducted the toddler ended
peacefully this afternoon they say the
child is not hurt and has been handed
over to his mother the 36-year-old
suspect has been arrested and is
speaking with investigators so far no
charges have been laid
it's been nearly a week since hurricane
ida made landfall in louisiana and
unleashed a deadly deluge and the
ensuing disaster has exposed how
ill-prepared the u.s is for the climate
crisis extreme weather has cost the
country 450 billion dollars in damage
nationwide since 2005. but as jennifer
johnson explains the loss of life and
the emotional toll are immeasurable
the winds and rain from hurricane ida
are long gone
but the mud mess and destruction left
behind will take months to clean up i'm
just like this is horrible catherine
navarro and brainer garcia got their
first look at what was left of their new
jersey home few of their belongings
survived but they did why are you
holding up new jersey's governor has
been touring the hardest hit areas of
his state calling on congress to pass
president joe biden's 1 trillion
infrastructure bill to update america's
crumbling roads so they don't become
death traps when the next hurricane hits
we've got infrastructure that was built
for a different reality the alarms have
been going off for
for decades if not longer
climate change scientists say big cities
like new york need major changes
including increasing the water capacity
of street gutters installing larger
sewer pipes and replacing pavement that
better absorbs water we have a 20th
century or even 19th century cities in
some places in the united states
and a brave new 21st century climate so
there's a mismatch between what we have
built
in our cities today and the climate
realities in philadelphia major highways
that turned into rivers are reopening in
new york officials will rewrite
emergency protocols after nearly a dozen
people died in flooded basement
apartments the flash flood emergency
warning was the first in the city's
history many people were unsure of what
it meant i don't ever again
as governor or in my lifetime want to
see people in pain the way i did over
the last few days meanwhile in louisiana
seven nursing homes have been ordered
closed after they evacuated over 800
patients to a single warehouse ahead of
ida generators failed food ran out and
seven residents died this woman is now
trying to bring her mom home she wants
to be able to lay in her bed
but she said it it's just she says she's
in hell all of the patients have been
moved into other facilities among
millions of victims caught in hurricane
ida's vicious path
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up the refugee crisis european
leaders fail to agree on taking in
vulnerable afghans
[Music]
[Applause]
news of an apparent coup in guinea has
people celebrating in the streets an
elite army group sees state television
to declare president alfa conde ousted
from office unverified video shows the
83 year old in the custody of soldiers
the takeover comes nearly one year after
conde changed the constitution so he
could be re-elected for a third term
soldiers say they're dissolving that
constitution and closing the country's
borders for a week
six years ago alan kurdi drowned in the
mediterranean sea with his brother and
mother the heartbreaking image of the
syrian toddler's lifeless body partly
triggered canada's large intake of
syrian refugees it had a similar effect
in europe where more than a million
syrians sought safety in 2015 but as
redmond shannon explains the potential
for another refugee crisis from
afghanistan is being met differently
from the eastern border of poland to the
greek frontier with turkey parts of the
european union are putting up walls both
physically and politically if we invite
others from outside europe that will
change the cultural identity of europe
there are some countries who accept it
hungary is not among the countries most
of the 27 nations in the eu were
involved in the afghan war and were part
of the scrambled evacuation effort like
canada they still hope to help those
left behind but eu governments failed to
agree in a plan for all countries to
take in vulnerable afghans under their
so-called burden-sharing migration pact
the absolute red lines for the migration
skeptics in these conclusions were
putting anything in there about an
expectation on
numbers
in terms of how many
new people europe would resettle instead
governments could only agree to talk of
bolstering borders and providing aid for
refugees in countries bordering
afghanistan we need to avoid a
humanitarian crisis
we need to avoid a migratory crisis the
main reason for this is the memory of
the chaos of 2015 when more than one
million syrians fled a civil war and
headed for europe greece on europe's
eastern edge is still dealing with the
consequences and i think what happened
in 2015 was a mistake we acknowledge it
openly
we address the need to support refugees
closer
to the source of the problem which is
afghanistan since 2016 the eu has
effectively paid turkey to keep syrians
from getting to greece it has also lost
the uk as a member following a
referendum campaign dominated by
immigration germany took in hundreds of
thousands of syrians but most candidates
to replace angela merkel as chancellor
in this month's election insist there
can't be a repeat of 2015. i think it is
understood by european governments to be
necessary in their national domestic
context to be to be saying these things
when they're talking about migration but
afghanistan's relatively closed borders
and its distance from europe suggests a
huge influx is unlikely for now redmond
shannon global news london
the opposition forces protecting pangea
valley afghanistan's last province to
hold out against the taliban now say
they're ready to negotiate with the
militant group the leader of the
national resistance front took to
facebook calling on the taliban to put
down their weapons in hopes of reaching
a peaceful resolution with the help of
religious scholars the taliban has yet
to respond
still ahead revenge travel trouble the
turbulent times for airlines
[Music]
air travel is taking off again as more
restrictions lift and vaccination rates
rise but planes and airlines staff are
not at pre-coveted levels and the
pent-up demand has caught carriers off
guard as ann gaviola reports passengers
are paying the price
it's called revenge travel after months
of covet restrictions canadians are
flying to see friends and family or to
take long overdue vacation time but
staffing at major carriers has not kept
pace the airline themselves created this
mess that they're in some angry
travelers are sharing stories of delayed
and cancelled flights and what they call
insufficient customer service it was
just a complete disaster they basically
ruined our vacation
and they've been no no help up to this
point and to top it off they lot managed
on both flights to lose a suitcase after
the flight left i basically put my child
in the car and we drove to toronto
because i'd asked him you know when's
the next flight to toronto and they said
the next time i can get out would have
been wednesday or thursday which wasn't
going to help because my wedding was on
friday some aviation experts believe
staffing shortages are calculated
airlines didn't hire enough staff during
the summer anticipating a false slowdown
as people return to work and school and
business travel isn't expected to make
up the difference so it's a cycle that
they're in now they've got this peak
lasting for another couple of weeks then
it's going to disappear
and you know they're going to look at
parking airplanes reducing the flights
so instead of potentially hiring and
then laying off they're plotting along
and sometimes it's at the expense of the
customer owed a whole bunch of money
like still having gone a refund for the
flight that was cancelled in a statement
to global news westjet says our flight
schedules are built many months in
advance based on anticipated demand as
travel restrictions lift and vaccination
rates rise we're working diligently to
predict the balance and demand
air canada tells global that it
currently has more than half the number
of active employees it had pre-covered
though it planned to operate at about 35
percent of its capacity during the
summer of 2019. it says the impact of
covet 19 on the entire air transport
industry was extreme and unprecedented
restarting such a complex industry that
was dormant for so long is a challenge
for all industry participants
although airlines try to portray it as
something having to do with coffee in
reality it is a simple business decision
how many employees the iran is hiring
how much they are willing to pay for
those employees that's a business
decision that something entirely within
the airlines control i'm telling
everyone i know don't fire enough it's
not worth the hassle for now prospective
air passengers should expect some
complications and potential frustration
they should be prepared to pack a lot of
patience ann gaviola global news toronto
up next the games are over and the flame
goes out what's canada's final medal
count at the paralympics
canada's leyla fernandez has done it
again for the second day in a row she
has defeated a u.s open champion this
time angelique kerber of germany
fernandez is now on her way to her very
first grand slam quarterfinal this gives
her something extra to celebrate on her
birthday tomorrow when she turns 19.
and that wraps up a paralympic games
like no other the flame went out on the
closing ceremonies in tokyo officially
ending the international competition
it's the end of a long road for
paralympians from all over the world and
for tokyo the pandemic forced the host
city to delay the event for a year and
even when the show did go on there were
few spectators next up the winter
olympics in 2022 in beijing and then the
summer games return in 2024 when paris
will play host
team canada ranks 23 in the final
paralympic medal count with a haul of 21
medals five of them gold when it comes
to overall standings china takes the
crown raking in 207 medals with 96 gold
britain is second followed by the u.s
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is the sunset in redcliffe
alberta thank you for watching and i'll
see you back here tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]
you